Transcriber: Büşra Ülger
Gözden geçirme: Miraç Şendil
Sen yola çık, yol sana görünür.
Geçmişten geleceğe, tüm zamana
ve tüm evrene sirayet eden bir söz.
Rumi’ye ait. Yolu İran’dan Konya’ya
varan adı tarihe kazınmış Sufi.
13. yüzyılda söylenmiş olsa da insanın
özünde heyecan bulup yola çıkması için
aynı sözlere bakmasının
en ufak sakıncası yok.
Bütün yolu görmene gerek yok.
Sen yeter ki ilk adımı at. Rumi’den yedi
yüz yıl sonra söylenmiş bir başka söz.
Amerikalı insan hakları önderi
Martin Luther King’e ait.
Martin Luther, Rumi’den
etkilenmiş olabilir mi?
Belki.
Etkisi olsun olmasın kişinin
özünde motivasyon bulması
ve yola çıkması için gereken
heyecan daima aynı.
İlk adım atıldıktan sonra başını
kaldırıp bakılan o sonsuzluk da
hiçbir şey olmasa da duyulan inanç aynı.
Ancak kuru bir inanç değil aradığımız.
Azim etmenin ve çalışmanın
ahenkli dansıdır bulmamız gereken.
Merhabalar, ben Arda Helvacılar.
Bugün sizlere hayatım boyunca inandığım
en temel yaşam felsefelerinden biri olan
yola çıkmanın ve ilk adımı atmanın
değerini anlatacağım.
Bir tarih aşığıyım.
Girişimciyim, avukatım, eğitim
teknolojileriyle ilgileniyorum.
Hayatım boyunca hep bir şeyleri
deneme hevesinde oldum.
Çok defa hata yaptım ama ne mutlu ki
ne mutlu ki şimdiye kadar
hiç keşke demedim.
Bir yılları anlatan nice kitaplar okudum,
içlerinde nice hatalar gördüm ama
hiçbirinin sonunda keşke görmedim.
Zaten yapılan hatalar da çıkılan yol da
atılan ilk adım da düşünülmeden,
planlanamadan ya da talihin yarattığı ters
tesadüfler neticesi ortaya çıkan
mutsuzluklardan ibaret oldular.
Sen yola çık, yol sana görünür.
Konya doğumluyum.
1996′da Ereğli ilçesinde dünyaya geldim.
Şehrimin, memleketimin, dünyanın en büyük
şairlerinden olan Rumi'nin bu kelamını
doğup büyüdüğüm topraklarda işitmedim.
Seneler sonrasında girişimimle katıldığım
bir programda Hamdi Ulukaya’dan işittim.
Hamdi Bey, Chobani markasının sahibi.
Chobani, ABD’deki
devasa bir yoğurt üreticisi.
Hamdi Bey de Türkiye’nin
en varlıklı 10 insanından biri.
Rumi rehberiniz olsun diyor.
Ben katılmıyorum.
İnsanların hayatları boyunca takip
ettikleri yollar daima birbirinden farklı
olsa da sonuç daima aynı. Mutluluk.
Mutluluğa giden yolda bir rehber
edinmenize gerek yok.
Rehberler ile yolu bulamazsınız.
Rehberler size yolu tarif ederler.
Rehberler yolunuzu eşlik etmez,
liderlik ederler.
Kendi yolunuzu bulmanın yegane yolu
yine kendinize bakmaktır.
Peki, peki nedir bu yola çıkmak?
Hadi çıktık diyelim.
Nasıldır yani yolda olmak?
Bildiğin midir, gittiğin midir?
Vardığında hatırlar mısın?
Yoksa vardığın yer hiç düşlemediğin
bir tabloyu mu var eder karşında?
Evvela yola çıkmak öyle saf
bir inanış meselesi,
kuru bir motivasyonla birlikte emeklemek,
adım atmak, koşturmaya çalışmak değil.
Hatta vakti zamanında Avrupa Birliği ile
Türkiye arasında bir uluslararası
ilişkiler krizi yaşanmıştı .
O krize de sebebiyet veren bir laf vardı.
Türk gibi başla, Alman gibi bitir diye.
Hele başlamak, bu kesinlikle değil.
Çünkü başlamanın etnisiteyle, dinle,
dille, ırkla sizi siz yapan, siz haricinde
hiçbir şeyle alakası yok.
Başlangıç da sizsiniz, bitiş de sizsiniz.
Ancak başlayacağınız şeyin size
ait olmasının sebebi
sizin neyi istediğinizle alakalı.
Şimdi çok küçük bir örneği ele alalım.
Vakti zamanında hepimiz orada bulunduk.
Hepimiz, ilkokulda kara önlüklerle,
kırmızı önlüklerle, mavi önlüklerle
o ilkokul sıralarında bulunduk.
Zaman bu renklerin kombinasyonunu sürekli
değiştirdi ama bir şeyi hiç değiştirmedi.
O heyecanla, o merakla, o öğrenmek
istediğinizi sorma hevesiyle
işaret parmağınızı havaya sağladığımız ilk
o anı hepimiz yaşadık değil mi o anı?
Hayır.
Bazılarımız o heyecanı yaşadı ve ilk
sorularını sordular sonra ısrarla,
istekle sormaya devam ettiler.
Bazılarımız ise, bazılarımız ise o soruyu
sormak yerine başka birinin
aynı soruyu sormasını beklediler.
Sonra zaman geçti, heyecan geçti,
her şey tükendi ve gitti.
İşte, işte herkeste öyle ya da böyle
ortaya çıkan bir tablo.
Küçücük bir çocukken yaşanan bu şeyin
yola çıkmakla ne alakası var?
Parmak kaldırmak mı yani yola çıkmak?
Aynen öyle.
Ama tek başına, tek başına yeterli değil.
Soru sormak mı o halde?
Soru sormak da değil.
Yaratılmış en mucizevi varlıklardan biri
olan beynin merak ettiği şeyi,
bilgiyi bulabilmekle alakalı.
Peki bilgi nedir?
Bilgi, ilk adımı son adım
haline de getirebilir.
Küçük bir çocuğun sorduğu ilk soruya
aldığı cevap, bir girişimcinin girişim
fikrinin imkansızlığı veya 30′larında
birinin yurtdışında yaşama hevesinin
nakdi yetersizliklerden imkansız hale
gelmesi çıkılan yolda atılan ilk adımı
son adım da yapabilir.
Peki yol gitmekle tükenir mi?
Tek bir yol mu var hayatta yani?
Sen istersen tek, sen istersen sonsuz.
Mesele sadece sen dersen.
Yani mesele sadece sen.
Daha öncesinde Martin Luther
King’den bir örnek vermiştim.
Hepinizin malumu olan bir sözü var,
bir konuşması var daha doğrusu.
Bir hayalim var der Martin Luther King ve
o konuşmasıyla birlikte tarihe geçmiştir.
Milyonlara, milyarlara sirayet
eden bir konuşmadır o.
Fikri, heyecanı hala daha bakidir
ve heyecanlıdır, canlıdır.
Peki sizce o konuşmanın hazırlanması
ne kadar sürmüş olabilir?
Yani bir konuşmanın hazırlanması
günler, haftalar, aylar
hatta yıllar boyunca sürmüş olabilir mi?
Konuşmanın içerisine sirayet
eden o fikrin hazırlığı
belki yıllarca sürmüş olabilir.
Ancak çok enteresan bir şekilde Martin
Luther King’in o konuşması,
o malum konuşma doğaçlama
bir konuşmadır dostlar.
Çok enteresan değil mi?
Martin Luther King, elinde hazırlamış
olduğu konuşmasıyla sahneye çıkar.
Sonra kağıtları bir kenara fırlatır
ve “Bir hayalim var.” diyerek söze girer.
Peki kullandığı kelimelerin hazırlamış
olduğundan farklı olması
Martin Luther King’i farklı bir
yola girmeye mi itmiştir?
Belki. Ne önemi var?
Heyecan duyduğu, inandığı,
başarmak istediği her şeyle
alakalı daima adım atmıştır.
Daima sonuçlara ulaşmıştır.
Bugün adını tarihe kazımıştır.
Neden?
Çünkü hep yolda olmuştur.
Şimdi hayal etmenizi istiyorum sizlerden.
Şöyle yemyeşil çimenler hayal edin.
Ortasında da bir tane futbol topu olsun.
Futbol topunun gerisinde de
2 tane kale direği olsun.
Amacınız çok belli.
O topu kaleye gönderip gol atmak
veya elinizde bir tane basketbol
topu olsun mesela bir
tane de potanız olsun.
Amacınız o topu potaya atıp
basket atmak. Ne fark eder örnekler.
Şimdi soruma kulak verin lütfen.
O şutu çekmediğinizde,
o topu potaya fırlatmadığınızda ne olacak?
Hiçbir şey, hem de hiçbir şey.
Yola çıkmak ve ilk adımı atmak
meselesi aynen bunun gibidir.
Çekilmemiş şutların
muhasebesini yapamayız.
Yola çıktıktan sonra görünen ne peki?
Tecrübe, deneyim, belki
hedeflerine varmak.
Neden belki diyorum mesela
tarihten bir örnek verelim şimdi.
Enfes bir karakter, muazzam bir mucit,
harikulade bir ressam Leonardo da Vinci.
Hayatı boyunca yüzlerce
yeni eser ortaya atmış,
onlarca yeni buluşa imza atmış,
enfes bir hayat yaşatmış.
Birçoğumuz hatta dünyanın bütünü onu bir
eseriyle, bir ortak eseriyle biliyor
Mona Lisa. Enfes bir eser.
Kullanılan teknikler harikulade.
Hala daha araştırılması devam ediyor.
Peki sizce,
peki sizce bu Mona Lisa’nın tamamlanması
ne kadar sürmüştür?
Yani sorum şu: bir yola çıkıldıktan
sonra yol ne kadar sürebilir ki?
On altı yıl. On altı yılda tamamlanan bir
eser. Şimdi bazılarınız diyeceksiniz ki
o eser daha tamamlanmadı,
yarım kalan eser.
Değil dostlar, tamamlanmış bir eser.
On altı yılda tamamlanmış.
Da Vinci yol boyunca daima
denedi, nice sefer başardı.
Birçok defa yanıldı.
Hatta bir dönem İtalya İç Savaşı'na gitti.
Ordular için silahlar tasarladı.
Sonra döndü geldi.
Bütün deneyimiyle, bütün tecrübesiyle
Mona Lisa’yı tamamladı.
Hala üzerine konuşuyoruz.
Hala daha üzerine yüzlerce kitap
yazılıyor, onlarca belgesel çekiliyor.
Da Vinci nice denemesinde başarılı oldu.
Çünkü hep denedi.
Çünkü hep yoldaydı.
Tabii, Da Vinci’nin ürettiği
her şeyi bilmiyoruz.
Tıpkı, Londra Filarmoni Orkestrası’nın
2012 senesinde
seçmiş olduğu
dünyanın en ünlü elli bestesi gibi.
O besteye tanıdığımız bestekarlardan
Mozart altı eseriyle,
Beethoven beş eseriyle,
Bach da üç eseriyle dahil oluyor
ki büyük bir çoğunluğumuz
biraz ilgimiz varsa sadece
bu eserleri biliyoruz.
Şimdi bu eserleri yaratanlara baktığımız
zaman Mozart 35 yıllık ömründe 650 eser,
Beethoven 600'den fazla eser, Bach
binlerce eser ortaya çıkarmıştır.
650′de altı, 600′de beş, binlerce
arasından sadece üç .
Ve bir çoğumuz da sadece bu eserleri
bilmeye devam edeceğiz.
Yani dostlar öyle vurdum gol
oldu diye bir şey yok.
Ben ilk adımı attım yola çıktım ama devamı
gelmedi diye bir şey de yok.
Ben birini rehber edindim,
birini idol edindim,
onun çizdiği yoldan gittim
ve hiç bir şey olmadı demek de yok.
En başından beri söylediğim gibi,
yalnızca sen varsın.
Senin hayal ettiklerin, düşlediklerin var.
Bir de yol var.
Yolu öyle uzaktan incele dilersen.
Aylarını, yıllarını ver. Kaleye girip
gol olmayı bekleyen top, olduğu yerde
öylece durmaya devam edecek.
İyi de şutu çektim gol olmadı deme.
Bir daha, bir daha dene.
Daha önemlisi ne biliyor musun?
Şut çekmeyi bilmiyorsan müzik yap.
Kitap yaz. Hatiplik yap ve konuşmacı ol.
Ama dene.
Denediği zaman imkanlar seni bulacak.
Sen kendini bulacaksın.
Kendini tanımlamanın yolu kendini
denemekten başka bir yerde geçmiyor.
Defalarca dene.
Seneler boyunca dene.
Belki Mona Lisa’yı yaratacaksın,
belki dünya tarihine geçen elli büyük
besteden birine sahip olacaksın.
Örnekler bol.
Motive olmak serbest ama bir
şeyi kendine şart koy lütfen.
Denememek yasak.
Yolda olan birinden yolda
olanlara selam olsun.
Teşekkürler.